Olá se você chegou até aqui
provavelmente está preocupado com o
crescimento Benigno da próstata também
conhecido como hpb ou adenoma prostático
talvez você seja médico médica
profissional de saúde mas também é
possível que você seja um pesquisador
independente Alguém já avançado no
estudo de temas de saúde mesmo não sendo
profissional do ramo algo por exemplo na
linha de biohacker seja qual for a sua
situação eu acho que você Você tá no
lugar certo eu sei como é desconfortável
urinar várias vezes durante a noite ter
dificuldade no jato demorar para urinar
ter um jato de urina fraco além de
prejudicar o seu sono e sua rotina hpb
também afeta diretamente a qualidade de
vida mas calma existe sim solução o
tratamento natural para hpb é muito
eficaz evita os efeitos colaterais
indesejáveis dos medicamentos eu vou te
contar mais sobre isso agora primeiro é
importante entender que o aumento da
próstata não é totalmente inevitável com
a idade na verdade ele pode ser
parcialmente prevenido e tratado com
mudança simples no estilo de vida
alimentação suplementação entre outros o
tratamento farmacológico como os
inibidores da C Alfa redutase Podem sim
aliviar os sintomas Mas podem também
causar efeitos colaterais desagradáveis
é o caso da impotência sexual a famosa
disfunção erétil a a ejaculação
retrógrada ou ejaculação seca a
ginecomastia que é o homem com peitinhos
e perda do desejo libido nós vamos falar
a respeito da temida síndrome pós
finasterida ao longo do nosso curso já o
tratamento natural ele combate as causas
da doença e promove a redução do volume
prostático de uma forma segura sem
hormônios ou medicações e se baseia em
três pilares alimentação
antiinflamatória rica em nutrientes
essenciais como zinco selênio ômega-3
vitaminas d e licopeno encontrados em
alimentos como sementes castanhas peixes
tomate e azeite suplementação específica
com nutrientes fitoterápicos e
probióticos que inibem a inflamação
prostática e o crescimento celular
desordenado e modificações estilo de
vida com mais atividade física controle
do estresse e adequação do
Sono essa abordagem natural restaur o
equilíbrio hormonal reduz a inflamação
controla o crescimento prostático e
alivia os sintomas urinários sem efeitos
colaterais ou mínimos os resultados
começam a aparecer em poucas semanas e
se consolidam em alguns meses você volta
a ter noites de sono tranquilas jato de
urina forte e nenhuma vontade repentina
e urgente de urinar e o melhor sem
precisar se submeter a procedimentos
invasivos ou cirurgias
se você quer saber mais sobre esse
tratamento natural revolucionário que
promove saúde prostática e melhora os
sintomas urinários de forma segura e
eficaz é só continuar acompanhando esse
curso
online eu vou te ensinar tudo sobre
alimentação nutrientes ervas mudanças no
estilo de vida que vão transformar a sua
saúde prostática e também dos seus
clientes vamos juntos reverter o quadro
da hpb de forma natural uma nota
importante aqui muitos de vocês sabem
que eu lancei anos atrás o produto
prosta blindada em parceria com empresa
juvi e é bem possível que muitos de
vocês já tenham feito esse curso
anterior como esse curso atual é mais
avançado e aprofundado do que o prosta
blindada Eu recomendo principalmente o
atual para profissionais de saúde e
pessoas que tenham um conhecimento
prévio sobre o assunto embora seja
acessível a leigos determinados
estudiosos pode conter e vai ter termos
técnicos e alguns conceitos mais
complexos Caso vocês tenham dificuldades
busque informações complementares antes
de fazer as perguntas pois leva algum
tempo para respondê-las pelo curso eu
peço para vocês desculpa e paciência
nesse sentido Todas serão respondidas
mas toma algum tempo então o curso
próstata brindada feito em parceria com
a jivi continua sendo sim uma ótima
opção para leigos e esse curso de agora
que você está vendo pode ser considerado
uma versão Pro ou
avançada no próximo vídeo eu vou falar
um pouco mais a meu respeito quem sou eu
minha formação e vamos introduzir o
cronograma do curso te vejo lá você é
feira